Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Depuis l’enfance,
je sais que je veux inventer
des histoires vraies.
C’est-à-dire mettre en scène
le réel avec des mots,
des photos ou des sons, selon le sujet.
Ça a commencé
quand j’étais à l’école primaire.
J’avais créé une maison de couture
avec trois bouts de ficelle
parce que je ne savais pas coudre.
Après, j’ai monté
un groupe de rock a cappella.
A cappella parce qu’aucune d’entre nous
n’avait encore commencé le solfège.
Ensuite, j'ai écrit un roman
à l'encre turquoise.
Je faisais des petits cœurs
sur les i comme ça.
Bref, tout a commencé
par l’insouciance de l’enfance,
quand il n’y avait pas encore
d’enjeu de performance.
Et puis j'ai grandi.
On m'a demandé de choisir.
Moi, je ne voulais pas choisir.
Alors pendant des années, on m’a demandé :
« Mais c’est quoi, ton vrai métier ? »
Quand on choisit la polyvalence
dans un monde de spécialistes,
il faut donner des preuves,
des justifications
et surtout du temps, je crois.
Sur ma carte de visite, j’ai écrit que
j’étais « inventeuse d’histoires vraies ».
A l’URSSAF, on m’a forcée
à trouver un truc un peu plus carré.
Et c’est « artiste-auteur ».
J’ai la chance de vivre de ce que
je fais aujourd’hui, et de bien en vivre.
Mais le moins qu’on puisse dire, c’est
que ça ne s’est pas fait en un éclair.
Quand j'ai commencé à travailler, il y a
quinze ans à peu près, je vivais au RSA.
Je sortais mon premier roman
dans l’indifférence générale,
sauf ma grand-mère qui achetait
tous les exemplaires à la librairie,
qui les recommandait pour les offrir à sa
boulangère, à sa coiffeuse, à sa gardienne
et faire croire
que c’était un best-seller.
Place de Clichy,
c’était un best-seller, en vrai.
Après, j’ai sorti mon deuxième roman
et là, j’ai eu la presse que j’espérais.
C’était merveilleux ; j’ai même fait
la 4e de couverture de Libération.
C'était le Graal.
Sauf que pile à ce moment-là,
le livre n’était disponible nulle part.
Il y avait un problème de diffusion
qui a duré un mois.
Autant dire que quand il est revenu
sur les étals des librairies,
c’était plié, il était mort-né.
Quand j’étais chanteuse, j’ai aussi fait
des concerts dans des bars
qui diffusaient du foot,
et la tireuse à bière faisait beaucoup
plus de bruit que mon ampli.
Je ne vais pas parler
de toutes mes déconvenues
parce qu’il y en a une petite liste,
mais je ne peux pas me plaindre,
je sais où je suis née.
Dans ce pays de la liberté d’expression,
la liberté tout court, au fond.
Et aujourd’hui, j’ai la chance d’avoir
fait d’une invention d’enfant un métier.
Et la preuve,
c’est que je suis devant vous,
à occuper 15 minutes de votre temps pour
raconter des histoires vraies, justement.
C’est l’histoire d’artistes qui, eux,
créent dans des contraintes objectives.
À la différence de celles dont
je parlais, qui me concernent,
et qui sont différentes
pour chaque artiste,
les contraintes qu’ils rencontrent
concernent tout le monde à égalité.
Ce sont des contraintes politiques,
économiques, géographiques...
ou religieuses - très important -
et qui interrogent
notre rapport à la contrainte.
C’est-à-dire que leur manière
de contourner l’empêchement
pose des questions
sur la source d’inspiration.
Est-ce que la contrainte peut devenir
une force ou une alliée ?
Pendant six ans, je suis allée
dans plusieurs pays : en Mauritanie,
en Iran, en Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée,
à Madagascar et au Brésil,
rencontrer ces artistes
qui créent malgré tout
et qui se servent des difficultés
pour trouver leur voie.
Ce sont au fond des résistants
que je suis allée mettre en images
et mettre un peu en scène.
Comme Oumar Ball,
qui est un sculpteur mauritanien.
Il fait des énormes oiseaux en fil de fer
dans une république islamique.
Dans une république islamique,
on considère qu’il faut éviter
de créer en trois dimensions
car dans les ombres
peuvent se nicher les djinns.
Les djinns, ce sont les esprits mauvais.
Quand Oumar était petit,
il sculptait avec les fils de fer
qu’il trouvait dans son village
et on le laissait faire à peu près.
Mais quand il a grandi,
et ses créations avec lui,
sa famille a commencé -
plus que commencé -
sa famille l’a supplié
d’arrêter en disant :
« Tu vas nous porter malheur,
ça nous terrifie en fait. »
Oumar a essayé de faire autre chose :
il a fait de la peinture,
il a essayé de trouver une autre vocation,
mais c’était plus fort que lui,
il y pensait tout le temps.
Il s’est tellement contraint lui-même
qu’il est devenu bègue.
C’est pour ça qu’ici, on l’a mis en scène,
entouré lui-même de ces fils de fer
qu’il utilise d’ordinaire.
Il a exposé à l’étranger,
à Dakar, à Madrid, à Dubaï.
Un moment, il a pensé à partir, partir
dans un pays où ce serait plus facile,
voire juste possible, en fait,
de vivre de la création.
Mais il s’est dit :
« Si moi je pars, qui reste ? »
En Mauritanie,
j’ai aussi photographié Houleye Kane.
Houleye, c’est une autrice et journaliste,
qui est très belle -
vous le voyez peut-être.
À cause de cela, on l’a mise à la télé,
on lui a donné des textes
rédigés par des hommes
car on considère qu’une femme n’est
pas apte à défendre ses propres idées.
On a fait d’elle une speakerine,
en quelque sorte.
Ensemble, on a imaginé ce costume.
On lui a fabriqué
une robe en papier journal
pour dénoncer le fait qu’elle
n’était pas juste là pour faire joli
et qu’elle avait des vrais sujets à
défendre, une vraie voix à faire entendre.
Après la Mauritanie, l’autre bout du
monde, en Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée.
C’est au nord de l’Australie.
Pour esquisser un tableau rapide -
parce que c’est un pays très complexe ;
il y a 800 langues -
c’est un pays qui est tiraillé
entre la tradition
et l’ancienne colonisation australienne.
Il n’y a pas de routes
pour relier les régions entre elles.
Pour aller d’un point à un autre,
il faut prendre l’avion.
L'avion est hors de prix.
Autant dire que les artistes vivent
et travaillent là où ils sont nés.
C’est aussi un pays sans galerie d’art,
sans salle de spectacles, nulle part.
C’est-à-dire même à la capitale.
Les peintres vendent leurs toiles
sur les parkings de supermarchés
où, après tes courses,
tu peux aussi acheter une petite
toile pour décorer ton salon.
Mais il n’y a pas de différence
entre l’artisanat et l’art,
ou alors elle est vraiment infime.
On reproduit des gestes,
mais on n’en invente pas.
Alors ceux qui veulent s'y essayer
doivent crier encore plus fort qu'ailleurs
pour se faire entendre.
C’est le cas de Buruka Tau.
Buruka, c’est un des plus
grands pianistes de l’île.
Sauf que son seul lieu
de concert, de spectacle,
c’est le hall d’un hôtel
pour hommes d’affaires.
On lui demande de jouer les Beatles,
mais jamais, jamais, ses compositions.
J’ai vu un jour ce stade
avec ses gradins tout blancs
et ça m’a fait penser à son piano.
Un piano comme amputé des touches noires,
un piano à moitié, à demi.
Et on a imaginé cette métaphore ensemble
de la place difficile qu’il occupe
pour essayer de faire
connaître son travail,
ce qu’il a fait à l’étranger, lui aussi.
Il a beaucoup tourné
en Australie notamment.
Puis il est revenu car il s’est dit :
« C’est en Papouasie
que naît mon inspiration,
que sont mes racines.
Et si je pars, je fuis. »
Donc il est resté jusqu’au bout et sa mort
brutale l’année dernière, en l’occurrence.
Mort brutale comme celle de Tony,
l’artiste que j’avais photographié dans
les rayons d’un supermarché, justement,
parce qu’il dénonçait
la marchandisation de l’art.
Il y insérait ses toiles,
disant que ce n’était pas
un produit de consommation ordinaire.
Tony, il est mort d’une infection
généralisée très rapidement.
En Papouasie, à toutes les contraintes
que j’énonçais avant,
s’ajoute la contrainte sanitaire.
Il y a très peu d’hôpitaux,
d’accès aux soins,
et on meurt d’une conjonctivite
qui dégénère.
Ça crée quelque chose
de particulier dans ce pays,
comme un sentiment d’urgence de faire,
parce qu’on a très très conscience
de la précarité de la vie.
Les artistes sentent
que s’ils les remettent,
il sera trop tard
pour réaliser leurs projets.
Ils sont comme en train de jongler tout
le temps entre le possible et l’impossible
pour à la fois réussir à créer, mais aussi
pour manger et payer leur loyer.
C’est pragmatique
mais on ne peut pas l’occulter,
ni à Port Moresby, ni à Paris d’ailleurs.
Quand je suis rentrée de Papouasie
avec tous ces portraits
et plein d’idées, d’envies,
pour les présenter,
je me suis rendu compte que mon compte
en banque était complètement à sec
puisque que j’avais
tout autofinancé depuis le départ
et qu’il fallait peut-être
que je trouve des soutiens.
Donc j’ai postulé à plein de prix,
de bourses, de résidences.
Quasiment à chaque fois,
j’étais finaliste.
Puis je finissais très souvent
coup de cœur,
deuxième, Poulidor de la photo, quoi.
Et j’ai compris.
Au début, j’étais encouragée,
flattée, puis un peu frustrée.
Puis, j’ai compris que, même dans
le domaine de la photographie,
on aime les spécialistes.
C’est-à-dire que, pour schématiser,
même si ça change un peu aujourd’hui,
il y a les photoreporters,
qui font du photojournalisme,
et la photo plastique,
type art contemporain.
Ce projet, il est documentaire bien sûr -
ça part toujours
de la situation des artistes -
mais il est mis en scène.
Donc trop mis en scène
pour le photojournalisme
et trop documentaire
pour la photo plastique.
Les gens disaient : « C’est très bien mais
ce n’est pas la ligne de notre prix. »
Je me suis dit : « Est-ce que
je prends ça comme un signe du destin
et j’arrête ce projet ?
Je fais autre chose ?
Je me concentre sur des commandes
en France, des trucs moins risqués ? »
Je n’y ’arrivais pas.
Une sorte d’obsession,
qui me réveillait la nuit.
J’avais comme un sentiment de devoir.
Me sentant, moi, très préservée en France,
j’avais envie de témoigner de ces gens
qui se battent tout le temps
pour continuer à créer.
Je me suis dit que j’allais
partir comme je pouvais,
c’est-à-dire sans fixeur, sans traducteur.
Deux fois enceinte, d’ailleurs.
J’ai compté sur la débrouille
et ma bonne étoile pour y arriver.
Par exemple, quand je suis partie en Iran,
j’ai publié un statut en disant :
« Je cherche des artistes
à photographier pour le projet. »
Et là, j’ai reçu 200 mails.
C'était fou.
Le problème, ce n’était pas du tout
de trouver les artistes
comme cela avait été le cas en Mauritanie
ou en Papouasie, mais de les choisir.
Il y avait aussi une question
très importante là-bas :
ne jamais les mettre en danger.
C’est une république islamique,
mais à l’inverse de la Mauritanie,
il ne s'agit pas seulement
de pression sociale.
L’actualité nous le rappelle fort
en ce moment :
on risque sa vie pour un voile mal mis.
Alors il était essentiel,
fondamental, pour moi,
de ne jamais mettre les artistes en danger
et de toujours imaginer des photos
qui à la fois les mettent en valeur
mais préservent leur sécurité.
Par exemple, je suis allée photographier
un groupe de rock féminin.
Ce sont quatre filles,
elles ont les cheveux bleus,
elle jouent de la basse
et de la guitare électrique.
Là-bas, il est interdit
pour une femme de chanter,
sauf en seconde voix
si elle harmonise sur la voix d’un homme.
Petit astérisque très précis -
je me demande ce qui se passe
quand la balance est mal faite.
Elles ne sont pas
dans les clous de la légalité.
Elles ne sont même pas voilées là-dessus.
Donc j’ai choisi, avec elles,
de rendre anonyme ce portrait.
C’est le seul de toute la série.
On a choisi ce filet qui représente
à la fois le jeu et le voile.
Il laisse deviner leurs silhouettes,
mais c’est tout.
Quand je suis rentrée en France
et que j’ai voulu exposer ce projet,
je leur ai demandé quel nom écrire.
Elles m’ont dit : « Mais écris notre nom.
Et quand tu publies des choses
sur les réseaux, tu peux nous taguer.
- Mais sur votre page Instagram,
il y a vos visages à découvert.
Si je fais ça, on vous reconnaît. »
Elles m’ont répondu : « Bien sûr, on
le sait. C’est tout le paradoxe en fait.
Ce qu’on fait est illégal, mais,
en même temps, on est un groupe.
Si on n’a pas de public,
on n’existe pas. »
J’ai eu cette image d’équilibriste,
tous ces artistes qui sont
à la frontière du légal et de l’illégal
et qui essaient de tracer leur voie
pour continuer quand même.
Il y a une manière de se réinventer
qui est assez fascinante en Iran.
J’ai par exemple rencontré Pegah.
Pegah, c’est une metteuse en scène
qui s’est fait arrêter plusieurs fois
parce qu’elle fait danser ses comédiens.
La danse est carrément interdite.
Il n’y a pas d’astérisque :
c’est interdit... pour les femmes.
Elle s’est exilée un moment au Canada.
Là-bas, elle avait
des conditions parfaites.
Elle était dans un théâtre,
elle avait des subventions, un public.
Formidable, sauf qu’au bout
d’un moment, elle s’est dit :
« Ce que je fais, c’est du divertissement,
du théâtre pour faire joli,
mais ça ne change pas les choses.
En Iran, ça devient politique.
Ce n’est pas juste de la création. »
Donc elle est rentrée à Téhéran.
Quand je l’ai photographiée,
j’ai vu un de ses spectacles
où les gens dansaient de nouveau.
J’ai demandé : « Comment c’est possible
de faire danser ces gens ?
- Ce n’est pas de la danse,
c’est du mouvement harmonieux.
On a un mot en farsi pour dire ça. »
Je me suis dit : « C’est incroyable, elle
rebondit sur la contrainte pour l’élargir,
pour gagner en liberté d’expression
et en liberté tout court. »
À propos de liberté, on fait un grand saut
de l’autre côté de l’Atlantique.
Je suis allée au Brésil rencontrer
notamment ce danseur qui s’appelle Wenge.
C’est un danseur de baile funk.
Le baile funk, c’est une danse des favelas
qui a du mal à sortir du ghetto.
Lui essaie de tendre des fils -
c’est l’idée de cette image -
tendre des fils avec des disciplines
plus classiques, plus installées.
Il avait par exemple fait
une collaboration avec l’Opéra de Rio.
Il était parti en Chine
avec les danseurs étoiles.
La première fois qu’il prenait
l’avion, c’était merveilleux.
Quand je l’ai rencontré fin 2019,
tous ces projets étaient à l’arrêt.
Le précédent gouvernement
avait, par exemple,
supprimé le ministère de la Culture,
toutes les subventions à la création.
L’Opéra de Rio avait fermé et le fameux
danseur étoile était chauffeur de taxi.
À la différence de tous les autres pays
où la contrainte est structurelle -
elle est là depuis longtemps -
au Brésil, ils étaient
dans une phase de sidération.
C’était nouveau
et ils n’avaient pas eu le temps
justement de chercher leur résilience,
leur petite marge de liberté
à l’intérieur de la contrainte.
Quand je suis rentrée en France,
à ce moment-là,
j’étais très, très loin d’imaginer que
j’allais, à ma toute petite échelle,
expérimenter ce que ça pouvait être,
l’état de sidération,
une contrainte conjoncturelle
qui t’arrête du jour au lendemain.
On est le 16 mars 2020.
Je vais présenter ma première exposition
sur ce projet, au Mans.
Toute la journée, on a accroché les photos
aux murs pour le vernissage du soir.
Et à 20 h, le Premier ministre
annonce un confinement strict.
On ferme, on remballe, c’est fini.
Je rentre à Paris et me confine
avec mon enfant de 2,5 ans.
Je deviens experte de la pâte à sel.
Et en juin 2020, la même semaine,
j’obtiens deux prix :
celui que j’avais attendu pendant six ans,
le « Prix Carré sur Seine »,
et le prix Roger-Pic de la SCAM,
qui me propose, en plus d’une dotation,
une exposition dans une très
belle galerie à l’automne.
Sauf qu’à l’automne,
le second confinement est déclaré
et qu’à la différence du premier,
qui mettait tout le monde à égalité,
il y a cette distinction
« essentiel - non essentiel ».
Nous, les artistes, on fait clairement
partie de la seconde catégorie.
Je me dis : « C’est fou.
Ce sujet dont je me sentais
si préservée me rattrape. »
J’ai donc ajouté
la contrainte sanitaire à la liste
et photographié des artistes français
qui avaient la bonne idée
d’être tous disponibles,
puisqu’au chômage technique.
En février 2021, je préparais
une rétrospective de tout ce projet,
artistes français compris.
On avait tiré 40 portraits géants
à la MAC de Créteil -
c’est un très grand espace d’exposition
de 500 mètres carrés.
En février, donc.
Les lieux étaient encore fermés,
mais on espérait que les contraintes
seraient levées bientôt.
On a repoussé d’un mois,
deux mois, trois mois,
pour finalement avoir l’expo ouverte
au public une semaine fin mai 2021.
Je me suis dit que
c’était frustrant, bien sûr,
et en même temps, c’était
une si belle mise en abyme du sujet :
parler de l’empêchement
et le ressentir à mon tour,
devoir trouver des manières de faire
exister ce travail quand même.
Par exemple, on a finalement tiré les
photos sur des Dibond extérieurs
pour pouvoir les présenter
dans des lieux publics, dans des parcs.
J’ai pensé aux enseignements
de ces artistes
pour qui les obstacles
ne sont pas des murs infranchissables,
mais comme des opportunités
de déviation, de contournement,
d’élargissement des idées au fond.
Je suis très fière
d’avoir fait exister ce projet
et d’avoir contribué à mettre
en lumière ces résistants
qui se battent pour disséminer un peu
de beauté et d’idées dans ce monde,
même quand le monde devient complètement
fou et même quand ils sont fous.
Je trouve que plus on se bat
pour arriver à quelque chose,
plus on a conscience de la valeur
de tout ce qu’on a mis à l’intérieur.
En toile de fond de tous nos projets,
il y a ce parcours cabossé,
tout ce qui nous a permis d’arriver là.
Et ce que ça a donné au fond
de détour et d’épaisseur au projet.
Aujourd’hui, je suis inventeuse
d’histoires vraies, pour de vrai.
Et grâce à eux, je sais que
les contraintes rendent l’art nécessaire,
essentiel même.
Alors j’espère que bientôt,
on n’aura plus peur d’elles.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)